trailblazer emma watkins i know you're
so upset about this and now she's
hanging up her yellow shirt for good
posting a heartfelt video on instagram
alongside marley matlin emma explained
the ongoing pandemic has allowed her to
reflect on what's important in her life
and she's going to use her extra time to
complete her phd and continue her work
with the deaf community uh yeah emma was
the first female performer in the
wiggles history and uh was with the
group for eight years i talked to emma
this morning on my radio show the
razamoka show on kiss across the country
and
how she reacted to the massive
outpouring of support since announcing
announcing her exit have a beautiful day
everybody
i just don't think i was expecting such
an overwhelming sense of messages and
emails and texts and i've already
started receiving some fan mail here in
australia and i guess it didn't really i
don't know if i really thought about how
much of an impact it would be and i've
received such a pleasure
of messages i really feel so grateful to
be a part of
music and a part of people's homes and i
just want to say thank you and i'm so
happy to hear your voices and and you
know i feel like i'm in your studio and
it's so nice and thank you for
everything that you've done for us over
the last decade at least you know it's
been so wonderful to have met you both
when did you make the decision how like
how long were you a wiggle knowing that
you were no longer going to be a wiggle
like when you made the decision did you
did you tell the rest of the wiggles
immediately or was there a period in
there where you had made the decision to
leave the wiggles but still had to carry
on being a wiggle i definitely have been
deliberating for quite a while and i've
been um studying my phd at university
here in sydney for
quite a few years and it it felt right
that i needed to try and finish the phd
properly and focus on it and so this
really felt like the right time and you
know a part of me was really worried
about the touring and not being able to
you know say goodbye to every child that
we kind of see on the tour but you know
so many people have connected with us
via social media and watching our
youtube channel over the last two years
in particular that it feels like that
will always be there and so people can
always watch emma wiggle like they can
watch any version of the wiggles online
and i think that's so nice for children
and families to still connect with their
nostalgic memories of the wiggles